I miss this game Cry
I really don't...
I miss this time where we play this game, remember?
uh... yeah
Watch out for the Brofist
Oh he got it
looks like someone knows how to play this game
-wow that's really impressive man
goodness
-I miss this game
oh I remember this you had to walk up and then jump
wow
That's so cool
-goodness you're really smoking me with that yellow blanket of yours
-hey you want a blanket? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
see? well oh
-come on cry
Just right come on cry
I'm good... dad?
-don't actually jump
oh... what the fuck
- It says "jump"
- it's weird
yeah it does
It says...
What...!?
oh wait this is secret I remember
this is secret somehow.
I remember this part.
Oh, okay. alright where's the secret
oh yeah you get up here
- but you got to jump on each other.
- No, down here
*gasp* Oh my god!
I remembered.
ah
this is way harder than it needs to be, compared to what we could be normally doing.
maybe we just want to fall between those spikes instead of going all the way to the left, you know.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
This is like, pure 2014 content, right here.
this is really, yes.
This is OG shit
ain't nobody want this shit anymore
where we spent an hour trying to get bloody trap land two working
and we're playing this.
We're playing the original.
I'm just so enthralled with your platforming "prowess", I can't look away.
man I it looks like I'm the new king, huh
I guess so man. It's  just that - it's cause you got that blanket, dude.
- Fuck
- Oh,
it's the secret of the blanket
it just weighs you down that time, that's the problem.
oh man, this is so shit
I thought... I thought the game was more fun than I remember
Dude, that's nostalgia, man.
are we just old old and boring now
is that it?
it's might be that
it's - it's purely like...
you always want to remember the good times and you forget all the bad parts of those times.
oh yeah
why do you forget the bad parts
I want to remember the bad part
I feel like the bad parts are just too many
so you trying to like pick and choose the better parts to rem-
For fuck's sake
yeah
there's a lot of bad parts right here tho
Oh like that
like that
and like that
uhhhhh
you gave it your best. oh
Shut the fuck up
I don't know, man. There was this girl I used to talk to, a long time ago.
back in school like we didn't really
like have a huge connection but I feel
like there was something possibly there
if we really gave it a proper shot but
we were just too nervous and young and stupid
Alright...
Let's  just gonna go up now...
Ok, good.
oh fuck I remember this level
we're gonna be here a while
this one is hard?
yeah we were here for a while I remember
I ain't got a problem with it.
You sure?
Easy
Easy... Oh shit
It shots faster!
Yeah, man.
shit
Oh what the fuck?
what the fuck?
Am I...
Wow
- Wow
- Dude this is the one!
This one!
- Oh...hey!
- oh this fucking one
we were here for so long
I'll take the bullets for you
- all right
- I take the bullets, go Cry
I'm gonna do some crazy American ninja shit here
come on crazy american ninja shit
going in
I'm going into ah
I took a bullet for you
come on Cry
Go!
american ninja shit
shit
I got this! oh
uh... shi... uh
I'll take the bullet for you
alright alright
- I'm taking the bullet for you
- Whyyyy
take the bullet
Take the bullet...
you're not taking the bullet
fuck
take the bullets for me...
okay on three
now wait
you go first I go right after
Alright fuck it!
come on
see this is the one we were on for so...
This is the one
this is the one
goddamnit this is like...
wait wait for me man
wait what'd I say
- what'd I say  what'd I say
- waitin for you
what'd I say
I'm waiting for you
waitin for you...
what what I fucking say
you said you said wait for me I'm waitin for you
uh... okay
what'd I say
you said wait for me I'm waiting for you
what's happening
I'm I'm doing exactly what you said
Run through!
I'm doing but-
you're not running through
specifically-
I'm doing specifically what you...
look look look
why aren't you doing that
okay I think I think I got it
oh yeah?
okey I got it
watch this Cry
alright I watch...
Fuck!
that's an old school
mr. Pewdie fucking pie right there
god damn boi
that is some OG rage material
shut your mouth boi
bringing it back
ok yeah you do it then
- you do it then huh
- alright alright
you fucking do I'm coming
fuck
wait for me there cry wait for me
wait wait... I gotta wait!?
you gotta wait
- you gotta wait
- I gotta wait!?
Yeah
Fuck my life alright
Uh shit uh shit okey You gotta wait for me tho
I gotta wait this tight fucking...
Ahhhhh!!
I see... can I leave yet
I'm fucking dead
No!
goddamnit
oh fuck
Bloody trap land man
okay I'll wait for you
I'm a good friend
- you wait for me?
-unlike you
gosh I'm fucking wait
I waited for you cry
wait for you buddy
we can do this together
I'm sorry I've lost in your blinky fucking eyes *very attractive*
they're pretty
(pewds: rated [?] blinking) Cry: Are you having a seizure by chance? I don't know
I'm stignalizing (he means signaling)
to come save me
please
why do we fucking subject ourselves to this shit
I don't know we could play any games
there's so many other things we could be playing
better things if you ask me
It's my favorite... favorite game
ah... Fuck yeah! OH, NO!!!!
alright
we got try mode we got to try really hard
I'm I'm trying I don't know what you're doing
oh I have I've been just fuckin around really...
I mean you want me to try?
Okey... I wasn't really
try very hard...
got it
alright I'm just gonna let you do it
do-. you do you boo
This one's for you Cry
okay
This one's for you buddy
alright buddy
I'm so...
yeah boy
dude my fucking hamster ate its young, man
it was hard core
oh jeez that's
dude you don't
you know that right
like hamsters eat their fucking babies if they're not like good babies
Oh dude what... that's fucked up!
hamsters are fucking hard
why don't human do that
I wish man like
will actually no
some eat, like the umbilical cord and it's really fucking weird
eugh
it's not a good thing
but I mean apparently...
but it has so many nutrients
yeah well so does a fucking steak you know
like you don't kinda eat their umbilical cord(?)
wait they eat it for the nutrients?
something like that I don't know  it's weird
I don't understand
what kind of nutrition are we talking about here
like the protein
I could be wrong
will I get x-men superpowers or is it just like a lot of protein
I think it's just like you'll be like a really hardcore heavy
ah this fucking shit
I'm already expecting a lot of time here
ah
oh it actually isn't so bad
You think that... oh
Yeah it..... bad
oh fuck
hey thanks for the massage dude
yeah no problem man, you gotta workout, a lot of stress you got going on
oh yeah
I got you man you got to work on that shit
all those people trying to be like
"YO Dawg can i get a shout out"
fuck I got you
don't you fuckin [?] here we fucking GO!
so I'm also I've come to realize something
what
you call it the brofist right
yeah
it's not really all inclusive now is it
- what about the sisfist
- no
there was a swedish article that came out
that calling me like a man... woman hater
because of I'm excluding my female audience because of the Brofist
Really?
yeah yeah
females can be bros too though
No they can't they're not allowed
like people don't realize I do actually hate women
oh!
how do how do i time this jump
alright so... uh
got it
Uh there was the Brofist there
yap
fuck
I'm really glad that this isn't really a things people do that much anymore
what
this
exactly what we're doing right now
- I feel like it was just like...
- Fuck
(pewds: You kill me)
- piles a lot of
more stress on top of everything else if anything
dude do this still make the same fucking happy wheels levels?
yeah yeah they do it's incredible
people still play it
That's amazing
yeah I don't know what's worse people making their levels of people playing it
I mean...
I guess it's probably the people making the levels because
come on have some other fucking idea by now
yeah I'm thinking about starting a e-sports team to this game
yeah
don't fuck my shit up now Cry
all right
don't don't you dare fuck my shit up
we're good
- you do you, man
- we are so in sync right now cry
you know what you should do, dude
yeah tell me
you should quit YouTube and start a band
hell yeah what should I call it
God see that's the thing
you either gotta go full vulgar or full innocent
you know
volvulgar
uh
I can't stand this shit anymore
Yeah
understand
why we still playing
I don't know man
like honestly
at this point, it's like a Stockholm Syndrome
It's a good game, it's a good game
Is it tho?
I like it
okay I mean
you know as long as you having a fun time with
this all good
alright I wanna stop
I'm not gonna disagree